hello my friends and welcome back it's  Clements here with your free PS Plus  games for September 2016 your lineup  starts with lords of the fallen on ps4  in this gorgeous action RPG push back  the hellish hordes with weapons spells  and a good sense of timing no seriously  you need to be light on your tippy toes  to avoid terrible been the hold on one  second ladies and gentlemen because  there's another game on this month's  list and it's a legend we have journey  on ps4 the iconic story from that game  company that is won the hearts of gamers  around the globe if you haven't played  journey yet please don't miss it it's  the kind of bittersweet memory you'll  never let go as always PS plus members  get free games alongside other benefits  including online multiplayer on ps4 and  exclusive discounts on PlayStation Store  these games hit PS Plus on the first  Tuesday of the month but keep your eyes  on playstation blog to see the other  benefits PS Plus has to offer